[Música]
encontramos en un momento muy crítico en
materia ambiental estamos en uno de los
lugares más afectados por el derrame de
petróleo ocurrido hace pocos días que ha
significado el desastre ecológico más
preocupante de la costa peruana de los
últimos tiempos
[Música]
normalmente en la mañana yo venía a eso
de las cinco cinco y media de la mañana
me ponía a sacarnos muy pero ahora yo
camino por toda la orilla y los muy
estaban muertos
[Música]
esta es la que estamos evaluando ahorita
no está tan empetrolada pero sí hemos
visto que tiene la pérdida de la
impermeabilidad tiene baja condición
corporal y está deshidratado por lo que
si amerita pues como todos los animales
un control veterinario un manejo
preventivo con antibióticos antifúngicos
y una hidratación y vitaminas acción
[Música]
bueno nosotros en términos médicos le
vamos a poner que están en reserva no
estamos esperando ver como los animales
van respondiendo día a día
digamos que no podríamos decir en este
momento que ya todas las que han llegado
acá están están salvadas o están
recuperadas porque es un proceso
bastante largo
[Música]